[موسيقى]
مساء الخير على حضراتكم موضوعنا النهارده
هو عن الكاتب الامريكي الفذ نعوم تشومسكي
ليه بتكلم النهارده عن نعوم تشومسكي
الحقيقه اسباب كثيره متعدده نعوم تشومسكي
هو ابرز من انتقد السياسه الخارجيه
امريكيه وانتقدها من وقت مبكر جدا منذ
الستينات منذ ايام حرب
فيتنام اضف الى ذلك كما انه واحد من اكثر
المفكرين تعريه للمشروع الصهيوني رغم بين
قوسين انه يهودي اثنين انه كثير من الشباب
سالني على مدار سنوات طويله ترشيح كتاب
وكتابات تساعدهم على فهم العالم ليس هناك
اعظم ولا اعمق من ان تقرا نعم سكي
بكتاباته الموسوعيه المتعدده وبالمناسبه
هي كتابات على عمقها مكتوبه بلغه بسيطه
ثلاثه هذه الايام بتحل الذكرى ال 95
لمولده للحديث عن نعومه ت شومسكي انا
بستيف النهارده
الصديقه الدكتوره فدوى كمال عبد الرحمن
استاذ اللغه الانجليزيه بكليه الالسون
جامعه عين شمس مساء الخير معالي الدكتوره
النور اهلا وسه وجزء من تعريف الدكتوره
فدوى انها ايضا من عشاق نعوم تشومسكي صحيح
صحيح هل ممكن معالي الدكتوره ندي تعريف
بسيط قبل ما نبدا نتكلم عنه النهارده يعني
من هو نعوم تشومسكي لمن لا يعرفه نعوم
تشومسكي اساسا بنعرفه احنا المتخصصين في
اللغه الانجليزيه لانه ابو اللغويات علم
اللغويات الحديثه ا ولكن هو اكبر من كده
بكتير هو ك هو موسوعي في زمن ا تخصص
التخصص الدقيق بدا هو في الكتابه في كل
نواحي العلم سواء العلم البحت زي رياضيات
وعلوم الحاسب او الاعلام او علم النفس ا
او الفلسفه التحليليه وغيرها وله كتابات
في كل هذه المجالات وله حوالي اكت من 150
كتاب خلاف الكتب اللي جمعت من الانترفيو
التي اجريت معه وهي كثيره جداه كثيره جدا
وهي كثيره جدا لسه كان موجود في لقاء اون
لاين في الجامعه الامريكيه من كم شهر اه
وكان لقاء جميل يعني انا من النادر من
النادر على مدار السنوات الماضيه دي ان
اقرا شيء ل تشومسكي سواء انترفيو كتاب ولا
ابهر دايما عنده جديد دايما عنده ما يضيفه
طب معال الدكتوره لان الكلام عن تشومسكي
الحقيقه يعني يطول هو لو بدانا بموضوع
الساعه اها هو الراجل امريكي وطبعا يهودي
بحكم المولد يعني ا
وكان من اليهود الشرفاء اللي كان لهم موقف
عنيف جدا من المشروع الصهيوني وشديد
الانتقاد لاسرائيل هل ممكن ناخد فكره كده
عن موقفه من اسرائيل ومن الصهيونيه ومن
الفلسطينيين
ا قبل ما اقول لحضرتك ده مش بس انه يهودي
ده والده كان استاذ لغه عبريه و كان
ا فعلا ب يعلمه اللغه العبريه وكان متعصب
للغه العبريه وهو نفسه كان عانى من
المعاداه الساميه في مجتمعات فيلادلفيا
من المجموعات العرقيه الاخرى
زي المجموعه الايرلنديه او الالمانيه
كانوا بيعملوه معامله سيئه يعني كيهود
يعني كيهودي
واللي غريب ان هو اتجوز مش بس يهوديه لا
اتجوز واحده اسرائيليه وعاش معاها في
اسرائيل لمده سنه سنه 53 في الكيبوتس
و وكان له تجربه هناك مش وحشه يعني هو
مابيتكلمش عنها بشكل سيء لانه بالنسبه له
لان هو
مذهبه
مذهب يساري اناركي اناركي اناركي تبقى
صعبه على غير بعين ولكن هو يعني من عشاق
الاشتراكيه يعني نقول التط الاشتراكيه
وخصوصا اللي
هي اللي بتشجع الكوميونات
البسيطه اللي ما فيها نوع من الجماعيه زي
اللي كان بيمثلها مجتمع الكيبوتس في ذلك
الوقت هي الكيبوتس لم اللي يعرف هي
المزارع الجماعيه اللي اسرائيل اشتهرت بيه
وخصوصا في السنوات الاولى وكانت هي كده
بالنسبه للي بيحبوا الاشتراكيه واليسار
كانت حاجه تجربه مبهره انه كله يعمل
ويتساوى فيها الجميع ويعني كيها صوره
افلاطونيه بالضبط ك تمام مع الدكتوره
بالضبط لكن معارضته السياسيه بدات بشكل
حقيقي مع حرب فيتنام ا ابتدى يتاثر
بمقاله
لا
احد المفكرين الامريكان اسمه وايت
ماكدونالدز كان بيتكلم عن مسؤوليه الناس
سواء كانوا اثناء الحرب العالميه التانيه
سواء كانوا الناس
دول المان من الالمان او من اليابانيين في
ان انهم ازاي سكتوا وصدقوا كل
الممارسات اللا انسانيه لحكومات والجيوش
التابعه ليهم وفي نفس الوقت لم يعفي
الامريكان والانجليز
من الملام لانهم برض سكتوا على قذف
المدنيين اللي طبعا كان اقصى حاجه له
نجازاكي وهيروشيما طبعا
فخد الخيط
من ده بالضبط وقال انه اذا كان الناس
العاديين لهم مسؤوليه فالمسؤول الاكبر
بتقع على
عاطق المثقفين ومن هنا كان له مقاله مهمه
جدا سنه 68 اسمها مسؤوليه
المثقف بيقول فيها ان المثقف بحكم تدريبه
على البحث والاستقراء ومن
واتاحه الوسائل البحث بالنسبه له وحريه
الراي اللي بتكفل مفروض الجامعات
الاوروبيه
والامريكيه من واجبه ان
هو يرى ما لا يراه الاخرون وان ان هو
يفضح الممارسات اللي تتعارض مع الانسانيه
وحقوق الانسان وكده ولكن هو شايف انه
المثقفين في ذلك الوقت قد تم تدجينه
تدجينه بالمناصب وبعيشه
الرغده بالبست زي ما بنقول وانهم عندهم
اللي بنقول عليه سلف كومب
اللي هو رضا عن النفس انهم شايفين ان
طريقه الحياه
الامريكيه وصلت ل زي دايما لما تتكلم مع
واحد امريكان امريكاني يقوللك انديس
كانتري احنا اه احنا بنعمل كذا في هذه
البلد ايوه يعني كان يعني ايه احنا وصلنا
يعني فهم فعلا كان بيقول ان هم للاسف ان
طبقه المثقفين التي يقع على عاتقها انها
تبصر الناس بالحقيقه ما بتعملش ده وانه دي
مسؤوليه المثقف الحقيقي والمثقف الحقيقي
كما يراه تشام سكي تجسد فيه هو شخصيا ان
هو قدر يعبر حواجز الضيقه
للهويه سواء
الهويه او اليهودي عارض الاثنين عارض
السياسه الخارجيه الامريكيه بلده وعارض
الدوله اليهود العبريه لا وكمان عارض
بالرغم من انه كان
يساري وكده الا انه فضح
الممارسات الاتحاد
السوفيتي سنه 86 قبل انهياره
فكان مالوش
انحيازات يجري ورا الحق اينما كان انا
هناقش حضرتك في موقفه ممكن في حلقه لاحقه
يعني هو عنده شكل تصور وشكل معين من اشكال
الاشتراكيه هو متحمس جدا بس دي قصه ممكن
يعني لان هو كتير ممكن خصص حلقات كتير ل
ونخصص له مش بس بتتكلم عن تشومسكي منه
بنستفيد حاجات كتير يعني صحيح لكن تحب
يعني انت اتكلمتي على نقطتين نقطه انه
موقفه من اسرائيل ونقطه انه بيدير
المثقفين والعقليه اللي شكلتها وهو عنده
كتابين كتاب بيتكلم على تزييف الحقائق من
خلال الاعلام وعنده كتابات عن فلسطين تحب
نبدا بايه كم مثالين للافكار المهمه اللي
قدمها
تشومسكي ممكن نبتدي بدور الاعلام افضلي هو
عنده كتابين في منتهى الاهميه واحد اسمه
ميديا كنترول او سيطره الاعلام سنه 91
وقبليه ميفاكين كونسنت سنه 88 اللي هو
تصنيع الموافقه اه الاقتصاد السياسي
لوسائل الاعلام وده كتبه سنه 88 بس اعاد
له نسخه منقحه
بعديها ب 20 سنه بعد سقوط الاتحاد
السوفيتي لان كان جزء كبير منه عن الاتحاد
السوفيتي غير الجزء ده بالاضافه الى انه
دخل الجزء بتاع الانترنت و تاثيرها في
تصنيع الموافقه يعني
ا لو خدنا خلاصه الكتابين الفكره الجوهريه
فيهم ايه فيما يتعلق بالاعلام وتزييف
الحقائق والتضليل وغسل العقول يعني ايه
الفكره الاساسيه بالنسبه له ان الدعايه
تمثل للانظمه
الديمقراطيه ما تمثله العصا بالنسبه
للانظمه الاستبداديه جميله دي
فهو دور الاعلام في السيطره على الشعوب
و من خلال تصنيع الخطر على طول يعيش الشعب
في احساس الخطر ان هو لازم يلتف حول
القاضه علشان ضد خطر خارجي او تصنيع بقى
الخطر ده سواء يعني كان في وقت من الاوقات
الشيوعيه والاتحاد السوفيتي او من خلال
تصنيع هذا
الخطر يلتف الشعب حول
قادته وما يبتدي يتساءل بقى يعني خلاص
هياخد اللي بيقولوه ويخضع للبروباجندا
المسيسه يعني هو يعني للتبسيط هي دي طبعا
الفكره دي شومسكي بيقولها واخرين اعتقد
سمول
هتنتن مره قال ان واحده من الافكار
الاساسيه للمجتمع الامريكي ان مجتمع
مهاجرين وعنده فئات كتيره واعراق كتيره
فدايما يدور على عدو خارجي يوحد كل الفئات
دي مع بعض صص العدو ده يبقى في فتره من
الفترات المهاجرين الصينيين في القرن ال
19 يلاقي الاتحاد السوفيتي بعد ظهوره
يلاقي بعد كده الارهاب ما يسمى الارهاب
الاسلامي دايما هيدور على على خطر واحيانا
بيكون خطر مضحك يعني انه العراق الدوله
الصغيره دي هتدمر العالم كله كوريا الدوله
المحاصره بقى لها من سنه 53 خطر شديد على
الولايات المتحده وهكذا يعني ص وهو بيفرق
هناه بين نوعين من الحروب ال اللي بقدها
الولايات
المتحده البريف والبري اميف اه الوقائيه
والباقيه الاستباقيه فواحده منهم اللي هي
البريفنج دي ما بيبقاش في خطر حقيقي لكن
هو خطر متصور او خطر بعيد زي الحرب على
العراق اه لكن البتف هو بيقول ان هو هي دي
اوكي لانها دي استباقيه ده معناه ان في
خطر محدق وانا بذبه واضرب علشان ما تضربش
يعني العراق ما كانتش طبعا تشكل اي خطر
على حقيقي على الولايات المتحده ولكن تم
ضربها
ا هو كان التصور هي ليه من وجهه نظرهم
العراق انا بذكر يعني الناس انه هو ليه
بيصور العلاق على انها حرب وقائيه انه
بيقولوا ان هي بتطور اسلحه دمر شامل ولو
تركناها هذه الاسلحه اللي هو الخطر
المحتمل هيكت مل وان لم تضرب به الولايات
المتحده هتضرب مصالحها وحليفتها طبعا في
الولايات المتحده اسرائيل ف يعني قبل
الراجل ما يفكر انه يطور السلاح الدمري
الشامل وقبل ما يفكر انه يستخدمه ندمر
البلد كلها
زي ما نكون ايه بنحكم بالنوايا يعني انا
شايف نيتك فمن
الاول مثال كمان بس ان هو ايام ا بن ليدن
لما قتل اه كان دهده قريب يعني في ايام
اوباما 2011 اظن يعني انا مش فاكره للاسف
اظن
2011 قال انه انه اوباما و سوري انه جورج
بوش الابن و
وبن لادن الاثنين مجرمين بنفس القدر اذا
ما كانش جورج بوش اكثر اجراما اكثر اجراما
في حين ان واحد مشتبه ب
وقتل وهكذا واودين الاخر هو
من صانع القرار وساوى
بينهم فده طبعا كان حاجه بالنسبه للقارئ
الامريكي حاجه فيري شوكين يعني حاجه
شديده انه بيصدم بشكل كبير يعني هو يعني
اللي بيشير اليا وارجو ان تصحين دكتوره
اللي بيشير اليه تشومسكي واخرين انه لولا
السياسات اللي اتبعها جورج بوش وغيره يعني
من الرؤساء
الامريكان من استفزاز مشاعر دول المنطقه
ما كانش ممكن بنلادن يبقى عنده مبرر
للظهور يعني بلادن ظهر على اساس ايه انه
انا شايف ان في دوله بتدعم العدو الر
رئيسي ل اللي هو اسرائيل وتحا بيها وتضحي
بذلك بالمبادئ اللي هي بتعلن وبالقوانين
الى اخره وفي نفس الوقت ومن اجلها بيتم
تدمير دوله زي العراق وبيتم ضرب دوله زي
افغانستان الى اخره فلولا هذه السياسات
ماكش هيبقى فيه مبرر كبير لظهور بن لادغ
صحيح وده ظهر اليومين دول بان رساله بن
لادن لامريكا بدات في الانتشار على
السوشيال ميديا
ولقت قبول في بين الجمهور الامريكي ايه
بقى الرساله اللي انا ما تبعتش يعني ايه
الرساله الرساله كان بيقول اسباب عداءه
لامريكا ده بلادن بن
لادم تتلخص في الحاجات اللي حضرتك لسه
قايلها دلوقتي وشفت ريلز لكتير من الشباب
الامريكي بيقول لك احنا شفناها ودي غيرت
نظرتنا
للامور فشيء مؤسف انه انه اعاد الروح
لشخصيه يعني ما هياش احسن حاجه لكن ما فيش
مؤسسه امريكيه واحده يا دكتوره اذا كانت
السي اي ايه اذا كانت المباحث الفيدراليه
اذا كانت وزاره الداخليه اللي بيسموها هوم
ديبارتمنت اظن ه الكلام موجود يعني انا مش
منذ ان بدات حرب غزه الا وهم بيحذروا ان
الدعم المطلق الامريكي لاسرائيل
هياتي بنتائج منها انعاش التطرف صحيح لانه
تطرف ما هو بن غفير ده وزير الامن
الاسرائيلي ده ده مكانه سجن لما يكون وزير
امن ومسؤول عن اداره القطاع هو ورفقائه من
المتطرفين طبيعي انه ممكن الناس يستدعوا
المثال اللي هو مثال يجب ان نستدعيه يعني
نستدعيه بالضبط بالضبط ايه موقفه من
فلسطين يا دكتوره ابرز حاجه لفتت نظرك في
كتابه عن فلسطين هو كتب كتابه مع فلسطين
مع كاتب اخر هو كتب الاول كتاب غزه ان
كرايسس غزه في ازمه سنه 2010 بس الكتاب
اللي هو
بالسين عن فلسطين ا كان سنه 2015 ده جه
بعد ما هو برض الاولاني كان بعد 2008 اللي
هو العدوان الاسرائيلي على غزه 2008 ده
كان سنه 2015 بعد عمليه الجرف الصامد في
يوليو 2014 بالظبط فهو شاف
انه المعامله ا لا انسانيه مثلا في في
سوريا او العراق او او غيرها بيسلط عليها
الضوء وبت تدان
لكن افزع منها بيحصل في اسرائيل ولكن
اسرائيل لها كل الدعم ولها كل التاييد
سواء من امريكا او من حلفائها الغربيين لا
لم افهم يعني ايه العلاقه بين سوريا
والعراق واسرائيل ايه المعامله غير
الانسانيه في سوريا والعراق اللي هي ايه
لان ايامها كان سوريا كانت الحرب الاهليه
اه فبيقول ان بشار يعني بيتعامل مع
المواطنين اه لكن فده يبقى مجرم فده يبقى
مجرم لكن نفس المعامله في للفلسطينيين
داخل اسرائيل او داخل فلسطين المحتله
بالضبط بالظبط
ف بالنسبه له مشكله اسرائيل انها نموذج
استعماري جاي من القرن ال 19 في القرن ال
20 و21 يعني خلاص ما عادش ف النموذج ده مش
موجود وقال ان النموذج الوحيد اللي يشبه
اسرائيل
هو النظام العنصري فاصل العنصري في جنوب
افريقيا اه واللي انتهى الحمد لله سنه 90
لكن ده لسه مستمر وبيقول
ان انت مثلا انت في ايطاليا انت مواطن
ايطالي ولكن انت في اسرائيل يعني عشان
تبقى مواطن لازم تبقى مواطن يهودي يهودي
اه
ف فده قال ان دي حاله شاذه في جميع انحاء
العالم وان حتى في جنوب افريقيا في نظام
الفصل العنصري كانوا محتاجين السود علشان
كقوه عامله كيد عامله رخيصه لكن بالنسبه
لاسرائيل هم مش عايزين ده هم عايزين
يتخلصوا من كل الفلسطينيين سواء يهجرهم
يقتلوهم ويتخلصوا منهم ويبقى في
العرق اليهودي النقي بس ليهم هم لوحدهم
ودي غير مسبوقه حتى يعني مش بس في القرن
ال 20 في اي قرن لانه دايما كان فكره
النقاء دي يمكن الحاله الوحيده كانت هتلر
اللي بيقولوا عن هتلر لان الراجل بعد ما
هزم قالوا عليه كلام يمكن مش كله قاله
يعني مش كله صح يعني اه صحيح بس على الاقل
يعني فكره التفوق العرقي دي يعني كانت
موجوده في النزيه موده صحيح انا عاو
استاذن حضرتك ان انا اوضح يعني ربما لغير
يعني يعني المطلعين او غير المتابعين انه
فكره الدوله الحديثه بتقوم على فكره
المواطنه ا انه امريكا روسيا مصر المغرب
اي دوله هي فكره هي دوله لكل مواطنيها ايا
كان دينهم وايا كان عرقهم يعني تعدد
الاعراق فده افضل ما تمخض عنه العقل
البشري انه تبقى الدوله للكل والدين ده
يخص صاحبه والعرق ده مساله ما تكونش تؤثر
على حقوق لا ايجابا ولا سلبا اي افكار
اخرى بفكر دوله قوميه ا او دوله مبنيه على
دين واحد تجاوزها الزمن اسرائيل استثناء
اسرائيل في القرن ال 21 بتقول انا دوله
وصنه قانون في
2018 على ما اذكر يهوديه الدوله ان هذه
دوله لليهود فقط مش ان هي يعني الغالبيه
فيها لليهود قالت الحقوق الاساسيه فيها
لليهود وبتس زي ما حضرتك قلت قلت بقى
ونعومه شومسكي لطرد مواطنيها العرب فده
يعني هو الامر يعني استثنائي وغريب يعني
بمباركه من الولايات المتحده صحيح في راي
برض تامسي ان اسرائيل بتستخدم طائرات
حديثه وسفن متطوره لقذف معسكرات ايواء
وناس ما عندهاش لا دفاع جوي ولا اسطول ولا
هو
جيش وتهاجم السكان
في حرب وتطلق عليها حرب لكن الحقيقه هي مش
حرب هي جريمه قتل دي بتعبير تشومسكي نفسه
وهو كان ضد فكره الدولتين لانه هو حل
الدولتين لانه كان شايف انه غزه في الكتاب
ده كان سنه 15 ان على سنه 2020 غزه مش
هتكون صالحه للسكه صالحه ليه لانه في
تزايد عدد السك كان ما في هي سجن مفتوح
مافيش سجن مغلق مغلق سجن مغلق
وا اساسيات الحياه مش متوفره ومش موجوده
اه وفي نفس الوقت هي مفروض انه حل
الدولتين كان الضفه الضفه وغزه لكن طبعا
بيقطعوا اي حاجه بتربط الضفه بغزه فاي
متنفس بره الحته الصغيره دي ا كان مقفول
طب اذا كان هو شايف ان حل الدولتين حل مش
فابل مش مش صالح للتطبيق باعتبار ان غزه
اصبحت هو كان بوقع ان هي تبقى منطقه وهم
بيحاولوا يعني ينفذوا نبوءته يعني فضلا عن
ان غز الضفه بقت كانتونات و معازل متفرقه
هو كان متحمس مثلا لفكره حل الدوله
الواحده ما هو ده الحل الوحيد اللي هو
بيراه اللي هو بيراه واللي كان برده ناس
مفكرين كثير منهم ادورد سعيد قال ان الحد
سعيد المفكر الفلسطيني الامريكي الشهير
صحيح انه الحل الوحيد ان احنا نخرج بقى
بره الدوله العنصريه دي ونعمل دوله حديثه
يتساوى فيها كل المواطنين بصرف النظر عن
خلفيتهم الدينيه والعرقيه في الحقوق
والواجبات زيهم زي اي دوله حديثه فطبعا ده
عكس كل التوجه عكس الاساس اللي قامت عليه
اسرائيل طبعا هي اسرائيل من القرن 19 كانت
فكرتها ان وطن قومي لليهود لليهود فكان
الحل الامثل ليهم عشان يحققوا رؤيتهم ديت
حل دولتين ان يبقى عندي دوله يهوديه ودوله
عربيه او دوله فلسطينيه هم افشل فكره حل
الدولتين صحيح و فالنتيجه دلوقتي انه بما
ان في ملايين العرب والفلسطينيين موجودين
يبقى انت بتسعى سعيا الى حل الدوله
الواحده يعيش اليهود والعرب اذا عاش
اليهود والعرب يبقى انت قوت الفكره اللي
انت بتحلم بيه على مدار عشرات السنين وهي
هم كانوا عايشين يعني هي مش حاجه جديده مش
حاجه حتت نفس دي كانت ما قبل اعلان
اسرائيل اه طبعا يعني هم كانوا
عايشين المسيحيين والمسلمين واليهود كانوا
عايشين جيران واصحاب و يمكن ماكانش
بالصوره الافلاطونيه دي بس كانوا عايشين
افلاطونيه بس كانوا عايشين يعني قبل طبعا
ما يبتدي موضوع
الهجرات الهجرات المت الزياده المتتاليه
والعصابات اللي كانت بتهجر
بال
وبتعتمد لكن لو كانوا تابوا لوحدهم من غير
ده كانوا تعشوا زيهم زي
اي مجموعه من السكان المختلفين لو خرجنا
بره الفكرتين وهي افكاره كتيره انت حضرتك
وانت بتتابعي تشومسكي من ايام ما كنت
طالبه في كليه الالسون وثم كا استاذه وطول
الوقت مسك بيفرض نفسه علينا بيفرض نفسه
بطريقه يعني انا مش مش مش ايجابيه ايجابيه
يعني اه يعني انا اقصد اقول للناس ان انا
مش مت يعني مش متعود قوي اكون مبهور بحد
او كده بس انا الحقيقه مبهور ب يعني صحيح
هو هو من الشخصيات القليله ا اللي فعلا
تستحق الاطراء و هو جمع بين حاجتين منبهر
ب جمع بين حاجتين فكره ان انا يكون عندي
اللي هو ال انتجريتي الاخلاق يعني
الاستقامه الاخلاقيه وان انت زي ما
بيقولوا
الانجليز تو براكتس وات يو بريش اه اعمل
اللي انا ان انت بتنفذ ان انت قولك وفعلك
يبقوا زي بعض بالضبط على نفس المستوى ده
اختيار يعني ده شخصيته واخلاقه انما هي في
حاجه مش من عنده يعني هو ربنا مديله عقل
مبهر صحيح فالراجل النهارده في سنه ال 95
لازال ينتج ينتج ويبهر يعني هو بيتكلم بس
ابطا م م كان لكن هو مازال مبهر يعني كون
ان الواحد يبقى ما شاء الله عقله يقظ و
وقادر على الانتاج في السن ده يعني ا حاجه
مبهره صحيح هو متعرضش لمتاعب يا دكتوره
يعني هو طبعا ا يعني بيكتب ضد المؤسسه
يعني ضد طبعا اكيد اكيد منذ الستينات هل
تعرض لمتاعب استبعد من اماكن اكيد اكيد ده
حصل
ومثلا ايان بابيه اللي هو كان كتب معاه
اونستين اون بلستين ا طرد من اسرائيل
وجاله تهديدات بالقتل وحاجات زي كده و انا
اذكر الناس بالم بابيه وحضرتك ضفي ده اللي
هو شارك معاه على الاقل في كتاب اوم
بلستين ممكن يكون شارك معاه تاني الم
باباي ده مؤرخ اسرائيلي يهودي لكن خلاصه
فكرته هو الهجوم على الفكره الصهيونيه
وانه الصهاينه ماجوش السرديه اللي قالوها
ان احنا جينا وانه كنا يعني نحمله
ودا لكم يعني جئنا برساله حب لكم ان دول
قاموا بعمليه تهجير قصري وتطهير العرقي
التطهير العرقي فطبعا تعرض لضغط شديد من
اسرائيل يعني وطر و ده كان شريكه في
الكتاب لكن تشومسكي نفسه تعرض الى متاعب
اكيد اكيد تعرض لمتاعب جمه لانه حضرتك
عارف انه كان في فتره من الفترات كان في
المكارثيه اه ضد الشيوعيه وضد
مكفيه دي الفتره اللي هي كانت في
الخمسينات والستينات فكره انه يتم استبعاد
اي امريكي يشك في انه عنده ميول الاشتراك
اشتراكيه بالضبط بالضبط ده غير انه طبعا
كل الناس اللي كانت ضد فيتنام كانت في
القائمه السوداء يعني وهو كان متحدث قوي
جدا ضد حرب امريكا في فيتنام وفضحهم ده
طبعا يعني اكيد عانى منه لفتره بس بس لانه
استثناء هو استثناء في كل حاجه لانه غزاره
علمه
وغزاره المجالات اللي بيكتب فيها خليته
لغايه دلوقتي هو موجود
فيوت بار كصوت بارس في في اكبر مؤسسه الام
اي تي الجامعه يعني جامعه اه اه اه هو
ملحوظتين انا تخيلي يعني وارجو دكتوره
صحيني انه انه طبعا استبعد يعني هو لم
يحصل على جوائز عاده امثاله يحصل عليه صح
لو كان شخص اخر ا غير بقيمه تشومسكي و كان
لازم ياخد نوبيل مثلا ا ا مثلا ده كان
ممكن يحصل على جوائز وتكريم غير مسبوق
ويحتل مناصب كبيره الراجل لا ما اخدش هو
جائزته دايما يعني انه انتشاره وقدرته على
الانتشار فده فرضه بنفسه لكن الحقيقه
للانصاف لولا ان هناك نسبه حريه احنا
بنتكلم انه الامريكان بيصدروا الحريات
يعني ده كلام نسبي يعني
نسبي صحيح لا يقارن باللي عندنا ابدا فلو
كان ت شمسك ده مثلا يعيش في العالم العربي
ما خرج من السجون لا خالص ما خرج من
السجون ابدا فرغم كل هو نفسه قال انه انه
مسؤوليه
المثقف تنبع من مساحه الحريه اللي مكفوله
له ما هو لو ما كانش في حريه ماكانش هيبقى
في تشومسكي اصلا صحيح انا اذكر ان ادونيس
لما خرج الشاعر السوري الكب الشهير ا بعد
ما خرج من احدى جولاته في السجن يعني
فقالوا له انت ايه يعني شايف ايه ده في
حوار منشور يعني او مذاع يعني قال والله
الحاجه اللي اتعلمتها ان الانسان العربي
ليس له اي قيمه في بلده وبالتالي لو كان
عنده مساحه ا هيعبر لو ما فيش مساحه لو
كان تشومسكي ما عندوش مساحه في امريكا ما
كناش هنسمع عنه اصلا يعنيي صحيح اه ده
صحيح صحيح انا جزيل الشكر معالي الدكتوره
انا اللي بشكر حضرتك على اتاحه الفرصه
للكلام عن تشومسكي وده شيء يشرفني ويسعدني
الله يخليك ويسعدك وان شاء الله نلتقي مع
حضرتك ونتكلم على تشومسكي في حلقات اخرى
ونتكلم على مفكرين انا عارف ان عندك
اهتمام بادوار سعيد جدا وهو يعني يستحق ان
احنا نتكلم عنه وعن افكاره جزيل الشكر مع
الدكتوره شكرا لحضرتك شكرا لحضراتكم
ونلقاكم في حلقات اخرى باذن الله